salut comment est ce que vous allez
est-ce que vous allez bien que ça se
passe bien dites le moi tout de suite
maintenant là maintenant bao commentaire
est ce que ça va est-ce que vous allez
bien alors il ya un peu moins de vidéos
en ce moment je suis en train de
préparer plein de choses préparer la
rentrée préparaient des nouveautés donc
ça va être super dont on descend un
petit peu le rythme mais aujourd'hui vos
comms' pas d'un produit super
intéressant c'est ce produit là c'est la
watch trois mondes connectés d'huawei
j'en ai déjà parlé par le passé il ya
déjà un petit moment et ça c'est une
montre que j'ai au poignet depuis
quelques jours et vous allez voir elle
est assez intéressante pour autant
est-ce que la web 3 est fait pour vous
est ce qu'elle peut vous intéresser
c'est vraiment ce qu'on va venir
regarder ensemble aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant de commencer je vous invite à
laisser un joli petit poussin petit
commentaire c'est pour l'algorithme
l'algorithme a besoin d'être nourris il
faut laisser des jolis petits pouces il
faut mettre des petits messages donc
dites moi comment vous allez comment va
la vie comment est-ce que ça se passe
pour vous et puis vous pouvez me dire
également si vous avez déjà une montre
de huawei si vous avez une montre de
huawei si vous aimez huawei si c'est une
marque qui vous intéresse peut vous
intéresser tout si tout ça aujourd'hui
on va regarder ça c'est une vidéo qui
réalise en partenariat avec huawei on va
où il m'a dit tiens monsieur groupe ça
t'intéresserait de présenter la web
watch trois jeux toujours très curieux
intéressés parce que tu es huawei vous
savez quoi où et à développer son propre
catalogue d'applications il arrive
également avec un os harmonie ouest
enfants dans la voiture sont super
intéressant qui se passe du côté de chez
huawei voir un peu ce qu'ils viennent
vous proposez leur regarder aller là
alors ça c'est la boîte la boîte aller
simple on est dans une monde premium on
est à jean le tarif tout de suite on est
à 399 euros sans cette montre tarif de
lancement donc on est vraiment dans une
monde premium
le packaging est également à la hauteur
ici vous pouvez vous avez la galerie la
bulgarie s'était offre d'applications de
huawei avec plein de références qui
arrive on va regarder ce qu'on peut
retrouver ici en termes de catalogue
d'applications directement dans cette
montre à l'intérieur il ya la montre qui
est là vous avez le chargeur qui se
situe juste sur le côté bracelet cuir
kit surpiqûres blanches
j'ai le petit naming huawei au poignet
ça marche franchement elle est sympa
l'élégante on peut venir changer le
bracelet si on le souhaite en fonction
de ses goûts en fonction sur un truc un
peu plus habillée un truc un peu plus
sportswear eu des grosses nouveautés au
niveau du design sur cette montée cette
couronne qui servira de navigation avec
ce courant devait pouvoir venir gérer la
navigation dans le menu le zoom le des
zooms la gestion du volume la gestion de
la luminosité
ça c'est un modèle ici qu'on a au 46 mm
vous avez en beauté qui complètement en
acier inoxydable
vous venez pouvoir changer votre
bracelet ici on voit qu'on est en cuir
ça vous le marquis sylla genuis leader
le dos est en céramique
ça vous permettra notamment d'avoir de
la recharge en induction et si vous
souhaitez faire du sport ce que je
conseille ça devait reprendre ici un
bracelet en silicone au lieu du bracelet
en cuir on va pas aller dans une piscine
avec un bracelet en cuir on va éviter
lors de d'efforts et bien d'avoir un
bracelet en cuir mieux vaut avoir un
bracelet en silicone ça sera beaucoup
mieux
nous ce qui nous intéressait c'est toute
la partie connectés donc tout ce que
vous allez retrouver ici dans votre
écran à la première chose regardez vous
avez deux buts
le premier bouton vous appuyez dessus
vous arrivez dans votre nouveau à venir
zoomer dézoomer hard et ça c'est très
cool et le deuxième bouton que vous avez
en dessous il est personnalisable je
vais vous montrer dans les paramètres
et si je les ai mis sur le sport mais
vous pouvez très bien lui attribuer une
autre action très très facilement on
revient en arrière on appuie là où alors
on revit en arrière on vient comme ça
sur le haut vous venez bien vous avez
vous raccourcis vous voyez votre niveau
de batterie bout tous connectés ou pas
vous voyez la date pouvaient venir
drainé si vous avez un petit peu d'eau
vous appuyez donc à vous pouvez parce
qu'en plus elle est résistante à l'eau
jusqu'à 5 atm donc ça c'est bien sa ktm
50 m donc on pouvait la prendre pour du
sport quand j'ai juste votre bracelet
vous mettez un bracelet qui ira beaucoup
mieux qui sera adapté trouvé mon
téléphone vous appuyer sa vie retrouver
votre téléphone
ça va le faire sonner un concert avec la
lampe torche l'alarmé compagnie sur le
bas vous y retrouvez vos notifications
obtiendriez compagnie sur la droite
tout ce qui va être activité votre
rythme cardiaque tout de suite là je
suis à 86 ici je vais mesurer ma spo2
donc là je suis à 98% très très cool
ensuite si je viens à checker ma
température alors ils me trouvent 31,3
c'est un calcul sera un peu moins précis
en fait prises de température
c'est vraiment au niveau de la peau donc
il ya différents capteurs ou là je suis
monté à 33 ça vous donnera un petit peu
je dirais une tendance vous verrez ou
est-ce que où est-ce que vous en êtes et
après pouvait venir personnalisés
changez vos écrans mais autre chose si
vous souhaitez supprimer ces pratiques
sur la gauche vous avez ici votre météo
et puis vous voyez c'est très simple
vous appuyez ici vous avez accès à vos
différentes applications alors ça c'est
marrant parce qu'en fait vos différentes
applications vous allez pouvoir les
afficher de différentes manières vous
avez soit cet affichage là on peut venir
zoomer dézoomer pour avoir une vue une
vue d'ensemble ou vend les écoles de
très très près ça marche pour une offre
personnalisée ici vous venez d'un cadran
de montre et lanceur lanceur et là vous
pouvez choisir d'avoir une liste c'est
un peu plus standard moi j'aime bien
l'autre vue parce que pour venir
naviguer très facilement c'est assez
cool
alors après pourrait bien choisir
différents cadran pour venir
personnalise également moi j'aime me
suis là pour très gros parce que vous
pouvez venir un peut interagir avec
voyez il ya un côté qui est super rigolo
pour autant il consomme un petit peu il
vous le mark moi j'ai choisi celui-là
c'est très énergivores vous en avez
assez aussi énergivore vous avez les
blocs ça c'est assez moderne et très
cool vous marquent le nombre de pas ça
vous marque pas mal de petites de
petites infos vous choisissez le blanc
également qu est très simple et qui
marche ça permet d'avoir des petits
raccourcis directement ici au niveau de
la respire
sion par exemple au niveau du suivi du
rythme cardiaque
donc ça c'est assez sympa également aux
toits qui est sympa pouvait complètement
venir personnaliser le petit bouton en
bas alors regardez ça ça va se faire
dans bouton bas et là vous choisissez
comment vous allez bien à signer alors
soit rien du tout on n'utilise pas
agréable c'est un peu dommage sinon vous
devrez ce que vous voulez l'agenda la
larme labit galerie donc six variantes
voulez télécharger l'application vous
appuyer la galerie ça marchera pouvez
vous dire maintenant je veux mettre le
baromètre les contacte moi c'est
l'entraînement c'est vraiment le sport
je suis pas un grand sportif c'est pas
moi qui va utiliser beaucoup mais je
trouve ça vraiment un sens et c'est pas
mal du tout l'histoire d'activité
l'entraînement puis les applications
vous aurez téléchargé également modalohr
mood c'est une application qui est
intéressante parce qu'en fait elle vous
permet de gérer vos messages directement
depuis votre smartphone de huawei parce
qu'il vous faut un smartphone de huawei
c'est sky news qui optimise et ce que je
vous conseille pas ce que vous avez ici
la galerie donc lorsque je reçois un sms
surmonter car en propre à ce jeu là ici
dans mon application but qui marche bien
que très cool là ça peut être aussi la
musique pendant des paramètres
voyez donc tout ce que vous voulez un
poisson ce qui vous intéresse et bien
poignard et signé au bouton du bas alors
je vends des applications qui sont
installés par défaut vous allez
effectivement la galerie ici catalogue
d'applications de huawei poignet reçoit
cherche exactement aux applications vous
appuyer là vous aurez un petit clavier
pour appuyer le petit clavier apparaît
on trouve très facilement ses touches
envoyés pendant que je vais taper
aurélien c'est pour voir que c'est tout
petit c'est extrêmement précieux donc ça
c'est vraiment chouette le tactile
marche très bien il ya une très très
belle précision ci-après vous pouvez pas
venir taper comme ça il ya vous venez
recherchez vous avez les applications
recommandées
c'est pas mal de petites applis pour
mettre à jour vos applications
application installée vous les voyez
vous avez vos paramètres et et vous
cliquez sur afficher plus et vous voyez
plus d'applications alors c'est un peu
le point un peu négatif aujourd'hui
c'est que vous avez quelques applis mais
vous n'avez pas des tonnes et des tonnes
d'applications c'est le premier truc ça
va se développer
vous avez notamment l'application petit
bond ou qui est l'apport de la
méditation qui est là pour le bien-être
qui va arriver au mois d'août
donc voyez il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent et des applications notamment
françaises donc ça c'est bien mais tout
de suite à sont pas complètement là vous
avez l'application des taux pourrait
venir installer par exemple moi je
l'installé vous cliquez dessus et vous
voyez que si tout est écrit en français
ça marche mais pour autant vous prenez
une autre application mac s'initie
typiquement et là vous avez tous qui
écrit en anglais il ya beaucoup
d'applications qui sont écrites
aujourd'hui en anglais ça manque un peu
d'application pendant francophone ça va
arriver ça va développer le catalogue
d'applications à
c'est déjà beaucoup développée au niveau
des smartphones de huawei au niveau de
la bernerie ça va continuer au niveau de
la mode connecté
mais si d'autres trouvent un petit bémol
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment cette partie
là vous avez une boussole vous avez le
suivi du rythme cardiaque je voulais
montrer vous avez les minuteurs vous
avez de quoi j arrive votre musique
également ici donc ça c'est très bien le
suivi du sommet c'est un enfant qui est
super intéressant le suivi du sommeil se
fait sur les quatre phases donc c'est
vraiment con pierre moi je suis par
l'utilisateur du suivi de sommeil tout
simplement parce que j'aime pas dormir
avec une montre au poignet mais
peut-être que vous c'est votre cas
peut-être que ça ne vous dérangera pas
d'ailleurs dites le moi dès maintenant
vos commentaires c'est un très gros
focus au niveau des mondes connectés
tout ce qui va être santé et au niveau
de la santé ici vous avez la gestion du
stress
vous avez la prise de température ça
peut être intéressant la prise de
température notamment poursuivies de
cycle menstruel par exemple pourquoi pas
pour venir suivre si vous montez si vous
chauffez si vous vous sentez malade et
pour tout ce qui va être activités
sportives
vous voyez où est-ce que vous en êtes
bon on a pas mal de petits capteurs qui
sont directement sur cette monde ça
c'est vachement bien bon les fameuses
halo d'entraînement vous avez également
ça c'est super intéressant pour les
personnes qui veulent aller faire de
l'alpinisme aller se balader compagnie
vous avez la pression de l'air vous avez
également l'altitude on vend ans qu'on a
une montre qui est vraiment accès santé
on a une montre qui axé sport on a une
montée accès bien-être vous avez bien
évidemment un agenda qui va se situer
ici aujourd'hui se passe absolument rien
l'application météo native et en
installer une autre part et si je peux
le faire application de sport native
également avec beaucoup de sport ça
c'est super intéressant
alors aujourd'hui j'ai rien fait un
voyez vous la concevez vous avez 13
programmes courts sont extérieures
course en intérieur de la marche
extérieure mange dedans le vélo paraît
la nage en piscine la nage en eau libre
la randonnée en montagne la randonnée le
course le trail prati sens assez de golf
vous avez le ski le snowboard le ski de
fond le triathlon le vélo elliptique le
rameur autres et vous venez
personnaliser la vue de ce en mode de
sport 15 modes professionnels et 80
cents mode entièrement personnalisable
donc si vous aimez sport si vous voulez
vous amuser en extérieur en intérieur
pratiquer du sport quel qu'il soit vous
avez de quoi faire donc ça c'est
vraiment sympa ici là vous voyez votre
fatigue en pourcentage avec le temps de
récupération donc une fois de plus on
est vraiment vraiment accès sport ici
charge d'entraînement vo2max ici vous
avez un gps glonass
en plus si c'est un jeu qui va chemin
sympa c'est que vous avez un double
chipset haut niveau de la performance
qu'est ce que ça veut dire faire ça vous
permettent notamment d'abord une très
belle autonomie
dans dix-sept membres sont vraiment loin
déjà vous avez de la recharge rapide en
dix minutes de charge est reparti pour
15 heures d'utilisation
si vous mettez une missive vous avez à
peu près trois jours d'usagé et si vous
ne mettez pas de issime vous monter
jusqu'à 14 jours d'utilisation c'est un
des gros points forts de cette montre là
c'est l'énorme autonomic vous avez
derrière alors une fois de plus son
autonomie ça va dépendre des usages ça
va dépendre que vous allez faire de la
is een pa delà estime si vous êtes tout
le temps dessus écran lui mais en train
de bidouiller en train de grattouiller
vous en douterez que l'autonomie vous
allez avoir un petit peu moins mais
c'est vraiment un truc qui est super
intéressant c'est que si vous voulez une
jolie montre avec une très belle
autonomie est bien ici vous voyez quand
même plutôt bien bosser ça c'est
vraiment un des très très gros point
fort de cette contre la fête un double
clic vous avez accès à votre multitâche
toutes vos applications pourrait venir
refermer naviguer très facilement d'une
application à l'autre
donc ça c'est très très très cool et
l'organe en tout cas savoir c'est que si
vous appuyez 5 x 1 2 3 4 5
ça vient appelé les secours c'est un
appel d'urgence alors bon ici je
l'enlève et il ya un autre truc est
super intéressant que vous venez trouver
ici dans vos paramètres regardez vous
allez y si vous descendez dans sécurité
et vie privée
vous allez sur un saut s il vous avez de
la détection des chutes ça c'est bien
pour toutes les personnes âgées il ya
une chute la montre va détecter et ils
vous le marquis si un appel est émis
pour obtenir de l'aide lambine chute
assez rassurant et même pour un sportif
qui par exemple se fait mal vous allez
courir je sais pas un trade vous tombez
il ya une chute
on peut venir appelé les secours ici
alors apprécié voyez vous êtes tombé
vous vous relevez vous annulez n'y a pas
de problème ça marche bien mais ça c'est
voyez des petits détails qui font qu'en
fait vous avez le monde qui est super
bien fini qui est bien pensé qui est
vraiment hyper hyper agréable
alors point peut-être encore un petit
peu négatif ça va être l'assistant vocal
que vous avez ici qui je trouve pas
encore super bien au point qui comprend
pas nécessairement tous et un autre qui
est assez intéressant si vous allez
pouvoir piloter ici la caméra de votre
smartphone dès lors que vous avez un
smartphone avec harmonie os
une fois de plus des choses qui évoluent
qui vont continuer à évoluer mais en
tout cas ça va dans le bon sens et c'est
intéressant et s'est couché c'est une
très belle alternative aux différents os
qu'on connaît il une très belle
évolution à la dessus du côté de huawei
on a connu des difficultés qu'ils ont
eues mais aujourd'hui ils viennent
proposer et voyez des solutions toujours
plus complète avec des applications qui
va arriver en nombre avec de plus en
plus des usages surtout ici une super
belle autonomie
une très très belle finition en plus de
ça vous avez une détection du lavage des
mains vous vous lavez les mains c'est à
dire comptait 20 secondes et vous avez
également un contrôle par gestes si par
exemple quelqu'un vous appelle voulait
pas répondre vous posez là même que
c'est terminé sa le jette sur le
répondeur vous êtes tranquilles envoyez
moi j'aime bien cette moi parce que je
la trouvais ça super bien fini très très
très jolie toute la partie os et bien
travaillé il ya encore des choses à
venir faire évoluer au niveau du
catalogue d'applications mais c'est des
choses qui je vous le dis vont évoluer
avec différentes applications et
notamment petits bobos pour venir être
zen lorsqu'il vous montre que vous êtes
stressé
vous mettez un petit coup de méditation
vous êtes pena et c'est une très jolie
monde qui ira parfaitement bien avec
votre smartphone de huawei une fois de
plus le lien est en bas dans la
description on est sur du premium 399
euros au moment du lancement
mais c'est vraiment un produit qui est
très content si vous êtes dans
l'écosystème avec l'app galerie et vous
voulez une très jolie montre et bien
franchement que bien vouloir commander
parce qu'elle est sympa elle va loin on
a une très belle de nomi a vous de me
dire vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
on commence à comment le trouvez cette
montre bien pas bien elle vous plaît et
vous paie pas ou fait plus ciel vous
intéresse le lien est en bas dans la
description prenez soin de vous des gros
bisous à très bientôt de l'amour et puis
surtout on va très très vite
trith promis des bisontins